good morning John it's a pretty
well-known phenomenon that negative
events affect us more than positive ones
this kind of sucks obviously why can't I
like sit in bed and just like over and
over again all night long I just can't
stop thinking about that time a girl
said I was cute maybe it's helpful to
like think about why this is first
though it's helpful for me to know that
it's normal that everybody does it
almost and there's nothing wrong with me
for feeling this way which is nice now
it's tempting to go back to some kind of
evolutionary answer like why would it be
good for early humans to wait negative
experiences more heavily and yeah this
does make some sense like if I go and I
attack a moose and I win then that's
like great I got some moose meat but
eventually you got to go get more moose
meat but it only takes one time for the
moose to kill you for you to be dead
forever and that extends to more than
just physical threats for a prehistoric
human getting ostracized from your
social group from your tribe like not
fitting in could be a kind of death
sentence trying to survive without the
support of a tribe would probably be a
short and brutal existence which is
maybe why we spend so much time worrying
what other people think about us I'm not
saying it's bad that we care about what
other people think about us for the most
part on average though I think that
there are no that of consequences - it's
probably good to care what other people
think about you because it prevents you
from being really bad so we do care a
lot about those things and while like
bullying and ostracism is not the kind
of thing that's gonna lead to you like
starving in a field somewhere they can
lead to significant and serious negative
health outcomes so there's probably an
evolutionary reason why we should be
more worried about negative things than
happy about positive ones I feel like
that's a little bit of a cheat I think
it's gonna take like another step away
from like the biological fundamental
causes and understand kind of like a
little bit of the mechanism of it I've
been thinking about these things lately
in terms of identity a lot we work
really hard to create our identities
it's a little bit maybe what makes us
sentient like having a robust story of
self what have we done in our lives how
do we understand the world what are our
roles what are we good at and
get information that confirms one or any
of those things that's not a threat to
our identity we don't have to shift our
story of sell so that's nice
but it's not something that we have to
like think about it all but a new piece
of information that challenges any of
those things like that maybe you're not
as good of a soccer player or piano
player or human being as you thought you
were that takes work mental work to
either incorporate into our identity or
find some way to ignore or discredit I
think that our brains are built to
create a story of ourselves to create
our identity and negative feedback I
think is more useful in that process it
hits us harder and it sticks with us
longer you got to figure out a way to
force that new data into our old
identity and start telling like maybe a
little bit more nuanced story of self a
little less simple and maybe a little
less like shiny and pretty story in
which maybe we aren't everything we
thought we were and it's pretty normal
for a threat to that story to be like I
got interpreted as a threat to ourself
because I think that we this story that
we tell ourselves it is us like and if
you mess with that it's scary and you
have to deal with it and how we respond
to those threats to those negative
inputs with aggression or defense or
fear or avoidance or acceptance I think
that ends up informing a huge part of
who we end up being and how we end up
interacting with the world so I've been
trying to think about that thing a lot
John I'll see you on Tuesday this is the
end screen song there's things that you
can click on possibly maybe not if
you're on certain devices like the
description